notre gouvernement a adopté une attitude
généreuse envers les réfugiés
stephen harper est intervenu
personnellement choisi de fonctionner
d'une façon irresponsable pour empêcher
l'arrivée des réfugiés en provenance de
syrie
à souligner à quel point nous avons
besoin d'un gouvernement
meyer le personnel politique n'est
jamais impliqué dans l'approbation des
demandes des réfugiés beaucoup de
réactions aujourd'hui donc sur cette
histoire que nous révéler le globe and
mail ce matin alors je vous rappelle les
faits le traitement des dossiers de
réfugiés syriens auraient été suspendu
pendant trois semaines en juin dernier
par le bureau du premier ministre
stephen harper vous l'avez entendu s'est
défendu en disant que le personnel
politique n'avait pas été impliquée
alors on retrouve daniel à ottawa tâche
à toronto
michel ici à montréal bonsoir à vous
trois content de vous retrouver
bonsoir alors plus que l'on jour êtes
content bon daniel daniel qu'est ce
qu'il faut comprendre donc de cette
affaire quoique le bureau du premier
ministre
ici l'exercice en contrôle sont on le
sait depuis un certain temps qu'il a
beaucoup de pouvoir ce qu'on peut dire
même si l'effet sur le but de la
victoire ce soir c'est que c'est assez
inusité que le bureau de premier
ministre
ce cube de qui peut devenir réfugié au
canada ou qui ne peut pas le devenir
mais vous l'avez dit stephen harper son
entourage aime tout contrôler si venard
peu son entourage ne font pas confiance
mais pas du tout aux fonctionnaires
surtout ceux de l'immigration
on a invoqué encore une fois des
questions de sécurité sauf que le haut
commissariat des réfugiés des nations
unies a dit ce sont les gens les plus
vulnérables sont pas dangereux ils ont
été vérifiés on raconte des histoires
que le gouvernement harper voulait s'en
tenir à des réfugiés à autres que
musulmans ceux qui sont maltraités en
syrie les chrétiens exactement
est ce que c'est un moment déterminant
dans la campagne non sauf que ça ajoute
encore un élément ô
dossiers de ceux et celles qui veulent
la charge et de gouvernement dans dix
jours
tâche alors qu'est ce qu'il faut lire là
dedans qu'est ce qu'il faut comprendre
mais je pense que le fait que c'était
pour trois semaines indique que ce
n'était pas quelque chose qui aurait
déterminé un énorme délai pour beaucoup
beaucoup de personnes ces trois semaines
mais ce qui m'intrigue la danse et les
raisons de sécurité et je pense que
probablement on les aurait jamais le
fait que ce n'étaient pas publics au
moment que c'était fait me fait penser
je donne le bénéfice du doute dans un
sens au gouvernement là dedans qu'il y
avait une raison sécuritaire précise
pour le faire de réviser ces dossiers là
même si les les nations unies
l'organisme les avais trouvés dans
principe
alors dans ce cas là on saurait jamais
parce que les services de sécurité ne le
dirai jamais et le gouvernement non plus
et je pense que le fait que ça a passé
pendant sous silence pendant si
longtemps et probablement une indication
de ces raisons là où il n'empêche que
c'est comme disait khaless pour bureaux
du premier ministre de faire ces
vérifications de sécurité non non mais
ce n'est pas eux qui ont fait la
vérification c'était peut-être un
soupçon aux quelque chose qu'il aurait
été communiqué ont mené ces palmes ont
ce que je veux dire c'est qu'on ne sait
pas on ne sait pas la raison de sécurité
et probablement on le saurait pas si
c'était plus long que trois semaines
loge aurait des doutes sur la question
musulmane mais le fait que c'était trois
semaines me dis que probablement il y
avait une raison quelconque là dedans en
tout cas michel a donné des munitions
aux partis d'opposition
oui évidemment c'est pas une bonne
nouvelle convaincu que monsieur rap se
serait bien passé de la manchette du
globe and mail ce matin ça rappelle à
tout le monde ce qu'on reproche toujours
à monsieur harper espèce de frénésie de
contrôler et de manque de compassion
parce que on se dit au moment où
vraiment il fallait ouvrir les vannes
il y avait trouvé le moyen de ralentir
le flot de réfugiés
mais oui les deux les deux parties dont
on imagine la réaction
mais la façon dont ils ont réagi c'est
intéressant dans le cas de monsieur
monsieur mode qu'elle lui qui voit le
rôle de changement
le passé du côté de monsieur trudeau
aurait agi de façon extrêmement brutale
qualifiant cela d' abject là on voit que
pendant toute la semaine il prend le
contre-pied absolu de tout ce que
monsieur harper peut dire ou faire ça a
été la même chose dans le cas du
partenariat et dit qu'il déchirait cet
accord là cette fois ci c'est abject
alors que monsieur trudeau lui a été
beaucoup plus modéré dans ses réactions
du back to you pas de surprise on
connaît tous monsieur harper mais ne pas
déchirer sa chemise simplement dit bon
mais voyez c'est encore une fois la
preuve que ça prend un changement de
gouvernement et il est temps de dieu
c'est moi
alors ça a été pour monsieur trudeau je
pense qu'il va bien calibrer sa réaction
bon ya eu cette histoire de réfugiés
dont qui s'ajoute à toute la question du
niqab aujourd'hui que cette semaine qui
revenue en force après une entrevue donc
on en parle est un petit peu plus tôt en
lutin de monsieur rapport avec nos
collègues de notre collègue de cbe si
ces deux sujets les réfugiés et d'une
cas pour lesquels monsieur avait été
critiqué au départ finalement ça a été
assez payant comme on dit pour lui mais
là il ya de la nervosité comment
expliquer qu est ce que ça apporte
tasha à monsieur rappel de ramener ce
sujet du niqab mais c'est une bonne
question à poser parce que le débat
qu'il avait fait et où la position sur
le nikkei dans le contexte d'une
cérémonie citoyenne t et à une large
majorité de la population 80 % selon un
sondage qui sont de son bord qui disent
pour plusieurs raisons que dans cette
cérémonie là c'est inapproprié de ne pas
montrer le visage mais le débat sur le
niqab
le géant alimentaire c'est quelque chose
que oui on a eu au québec pendant très
longtemps des années sur la question des
accommodements raisonnables mais pas ici
au canada anglais le fait qu'il a
soulevés comme ça on se demande pourquoi
est bon une des raisons peut-être c'est
pour parler à la population en général
mais il ya certainement des communautés
culturelles qui sont peut-être moins
disposés envers les musulmans on peut
penser
malheureusement communauté m
un doux ici dans la grande région de
toronto ou les batailles très féroce ce
fonds pour ses comptes et où les
conservateurs doivent qu'ils doivent
gagner pour gagner garder la majorité et
c'est clair que ce sentiment dont on a
passé en anglais aux dogues ouesso
sifflé à un chien c'était de donner un
message un groupe précis sur une
question qu'on cible dans une élection
est malheureusement semble-t-il que
c'est cette communauté la selon les
sources que j'ai qui est plus ou moins
ciblé par ça daniel est ce que ça peut
se retourner on a vu quand même que ça a
été payant je les dis jusqu'à un certain
point on a vu ce que je n'ai fait que ça
a eu au québec
mais est ce que ça peut se retourner
contre monsieur à écouter ses voeux un
peu fait penser à un enfant qui découvre
une nouvelle saveur de crème glacée qui
aiment sortent beaucoup et qui en
mangent en mangeant mangent jusqu'à 30
balade
je pense qu'on a les rendus là avec le
dossier du niqab aujourd'hui le conseil
du trésor
la commission de la fonction publique
est l'organisme qui supervise tous les
fonctionnaires au canada ont tous les
deux dit qu il n'y a jamais eu une seule
plainte sur le niqab dans la fonction
publique ni de travailleurs de la
fonction publique ni de citoyens général
ils sont pas capables de dire s'il ya eu
une deux ou trois personnes aucune qui
portent le niqab dans la fonction
publique
bref de plus en plus il ya un espèce
d'agacement à l'endroit ce dossier là
des gens se disent est ce que ça vaut le
coup d'aller si loin de pousser aussi
fort aujourd'hui on faisait la
comparaison avec ce qui s'est passé au
québec moi je pense qu'il peut être un
peu boiteux sauf que monsieur un peu
peut-être total un peu trop loin de
penser au site achat que ça peut se
retourner contre lui mais déjà un député
a dit qu'il n'est pas confortable avec
un cadre des conservateurs avec cette
position oui oui je pense que ça pousse
loin parce que comme je dis il n'y a pas
un consensus public au canada anglais
sur cette question n'a pas été débattue
et pourquoi ils se soulèvent
ça soulève plein de soupçons et de
questions négatives gérait daniel
thibault nous parler un peu de nervosité
qu'on sent dans le camp conservateur en
ce moment toutes les entrevues ont été
annulés dans notre île aux fleurs vous
me permettez très rapidement et qui
explique s'être vu ce sondage
aujourd'hui où c'est loin d'être le
élire quant au partenariat asie
pacifique et beaucoup de canadiens c'est
presque plus que la moitié dans certains
cas qui ont beaucoup de réserve beaucoup
de craintes à l'endroit de ceux de ce
traité oui parlons de sondages ya un
contexte électoral on assiste à une
remontée du parti libéral même au québec
alors je vais vous montrer les chiffres
c'est le plus récent sondage a été
réalisé pour le compte du global mère ça
va être cool et demain alors regardez
les résultats le parti libéral qui
rattrape le npd au québec avec 28% des
intentions de vote
le conservateur sont à 20% le bloc est à
23 % à l'échelle nationale je veux dire
que les libéraux dans ce sens selon ce
sondage sont en tête avec 34% les
conservateurs à 30% et le npd à 25%
alors michel qu'est ce qui est en train
de se passer là on arrive au congé de
l'action de grâce les gens vont se voir
on se parlait lundi
comment est ce que vous lisez l'humeur
des de l'électorat la grosse surprise de
ce sondage là je pense que c'est le fait
que les libéraux ont rejoint le npd en
tête des intentions de vote au québec
que les délais les libéraux faisait bien
chez les anglophones il le fallait les
allophones tout le monde le savait mais
ces chiffres là
les squares qui y font aussi une percée
chez les francophones
et ça c'est vraiment un élément nouveau
tout le monde se dit bon et francophones
quand même un trudeau le parti libéral
les commandites ça marchera jamais et là
de toute évidence
d'abord je pense que les jeunes on
prouve que monsieur trudeau a fait une
bonne campagne ce qui le com et d'autre
part je pense que maintenant ils
réalisent que celui qui peut battre
monsieur harper c'est monsieur trudeau
et à partir de là même des francophones
j'en connais personnellement qui jamais
imaginé voter pour un candidat libéral
et qui maintenant envisagent de le faire
parce que c'est pour battre à part il
n'aime pas particulièrement trudeau même
s'ils reconnaissent que bien fait mais
maintenant c'est celui qui peut battre
un peu et si vraiment cette épreuve
cette impression là serait pas ça va
être désastreux pour le npd pour
monsieur moqueur achats et dans un sens
c'est monsieur a un peu fait le travail
pour monsieur trudeau parce que lui en
attaquant monsieur bill kerr au point où
monsieur le vote npd commence à
dégringoler ça aide les libéraux c'est
une balance délicate que les
conservateurs doivent maintenir surtout
dans les deux provinces qui sont
vraiment en jeu ontario et colombie
britannique
mais les québécois regardent ça et se
disent justement qui est là un tireur
c'est qui qui doivent choisir et là on
explique que bon il pense qu'il ya une
vague libérale qui commence dans ses
autres provinces et là il regarde sa
échangent leur vote aussi daniel alors
qu'est ce que les chefs doivent faire il
reste quelques jours à la campagne
est ce qu'on va voir du changement de
stratégie comment comment savent qu'est
ce que vous entrevoyez vous avez deux vu
thomas mulcair retourner à gauche
complètement prendre comme michel
expliqué du tout prendre et je sais de
rudo et s'il veut un peu à contre pied
sur à peu près tous les dossiers
ça semble un peu désespérée dans son cas
est ce qu'il peut remonter la cote
aaron cher a expliqué être de plus en
plus des canadiens sont conscients
qu'ils ont peut battre stephen harper
site avec justin trudeau
sauf que il faut jamais sous-estimer
gelé déjà fait à mon grand regret faut
jamais sous-estimer stephen harper à sa
base est toujours très solide très très
solide
sa moto rapidement mais des très solides
et la journée d'élection sur le terrain
la meilleure organisation et dix fois
plus d'argent qu'ils peuvent en dépenser
alors rien n'est joué ça va être
passionnant et au québec cette fois là
il y aura pas de vague à la trudeau ou à
la môle rooney ou à la lucien bouchard
et u7 ça risque d'aller dans toutes les
directions et là aussi pour nous les
observateurs ça va être passionnant mais
on va se coucher tard c'est saint michel
au web merci beaucoup à vous trois ans
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine ce
sera notre dernière table ronde avant
avant ne dit mot d'ordre qui ont décru
ce temps on a commencé le 2 où ça fait
quand même merci beaucoup en trois îles
dimanche à 11 heures aux coulisses du
pouvoir emmanuelle latraverse reçoit
denis lebel lieutenant politique de
stephen harper au québec